up guys my name is kim and i'm here in
cal anderson park aka chop aka chad
i'm just here to soak in the energy
become one of the people
let's go check it out
over here we have a light post
the crawl right here look at that crow
it's full of antarctic energy
it doesn't give a [ __ ]
it's so close to us and it's just
chilling because it feels
the the freedom of the people and feels
that energy
is one power to you crow
power to the crows
of anarchy and keep the territory we
don't throw things away
because we are the neither trash
seattle just like you needed texas you
can't just all be texas
you're a little liberal or else you're
going to turn into goddamn mississippi
you have a texas you need a seattle i
can't just have all texas joe rogan
[Music]
[Music]
uppercut
move forward three times one more one
world war two one more three
i gotta
you want kids to swing around but we
also want
justice as like a combination of both
there might be a lot of uh fragrance and
homeless but they respect the playground
as long as you're gonna get hysterectomy
at the border and bring your kids here
where you can play flag football you
play ultimate
ultimate frisbee right here there's way
too much freedom
over here the astroturf
area where everything is in straight
lines
and you can uh draw a circle around
yourself
and just sort of stratify yourself like
you're in the suburbs
i was uh running off here once and some
guy was like godzilla
godzilla i was like oh my god they were
racist to me i'm so
angry and then i drove past the same
kids that y'all godzilla at me because
i'm asian and i'm running away from
something
and uh i drove by them and i was like go
get a bank account
i totally own them dude yeah i pound
them
i now we're here in the safe section
where a white man can be a white man
even if you're you know
a black and blue trump supporter
there's an area for you right here sort
of harmless looking like i'm wearing
really soft clothes
we should really not run over people's
heads with the bike tires